[Music]
all right let's get to
dennis
in milwaukee
what's up dennis
hey john how are you i'm good brother
how are you man
hey good
what's up hey so i uh i got a question
for you sorry i'm a little bit nervous
hey don't be nervous man i'm not that
good at this show dude
you'll be the better one on this call i
assure you what's up we'll see about
that
so uh i'm super familiar with the
process of like mourning relationships
that won't be what you want them to be
okay
and how did you become familiar with
that
my uh so i got to get breath
so
i i was born into just a pretty tough
situation
and uh
my uh my asus score the ten
oh wow
wow
okay
so it's a re that's not you weren't born
into a tough situation you were born
into hell right
yeah yeah
how old are you now
so right now i'm 32 32 okay
yeah um
how much how much healing work have you
done since then
um
basically every minute of your show and
that's about it
i appreciate the vote of confidence
dennis but i'm not that good man
okay so you've helped me way more than
you'll ever know well i appreciate that
man
so 32 you were born into the pit of hell
and
it's still got hooks in you
yeah and it it comes out just kind of in
weird ways and uh
so
right now
i've got a four-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old daughter okay are you
married and
yeah
how's that going
she's my wife is just the absolute best
she's
everything that's awesome
how
how many of these old patterns are
showing back up with your little one
as
as far as my relationship with them
it's phenomenal i've taken everything my
parents have done and i've done
everything i've destroyed it all and
i've just rebuilt everything from
scratch on how
i wish that i would have had it when i
was a kid
and my relationship with them is
phenomenal i need to stop dude and
celebrate you
that's incredible man
you stared it down you're staring it
down you'll be staring it down
and you said not my kids no more
man
what a brave man good for you dennis
it's awesome
i appreciate that
so i actually even had a i said i had a
guy at uh that had a restaurant over the
weekend actually stop me and compliment
me and
and my wife separately on
just
how we're treating our kids and handling
them and it was just such a nice thing
to hear that feels good doesn't it
i think i'm
dude that's incredible man good for you
all right so how can i help man
something's something popped up
yeah
um
so
my uh
my mom since she was born she's lived
really far away okay
and uh
part of her situation and and how she's
treated me as contributed to
my past but by living far away you said
that you said that in a very diplomatic
way did she leave you and your kid
yeah yeah
um she an addict
no and i don't know if she ever was but
she had us around
people that were very heavily involved
okay and
was she abusive to you directly
yeah okay
and did she let it happen
with other people
yeah okay
did she did she go to jail or she just
leave you
my uh
my mom and dad were in the process of
getting divorced when
when she got pregnant okay
and
when i was a couple months old she left
okay
i i know that you know this especially
looking in the eyes of your
four-year-old your two-year-old
that shouldn't have happened i'm sorry
that happened
thanks
that little little dentist was worth
more than that and i'm sorry
and so now she showed back up
yeah
how'd that happen
strange um and one of the things that
makes it complex is
every night i tuck my girls into bed
and i give them a special touch on the
facetime and
yeah
so i i give them that and i i hug them
and hold them and
just
it's just the best
and it helps me
but
it's hard to
it's hard to look at them and do that
and then think back to what was
happening to me yeah
so here's the here's the thing brother
you
are
staring down this forest fire of and
that's just a quote terence reel i love
it this forest fire family trauma
you're a little baby dropped in the
middle of hell and you shouldn't have
been but you were
and you have made it your life's mission
to grit and flex
and become iron
in defense of those girls and your
marriage
right
yep
100
nobody gets through them
you're even lucky i'm talking to you
exactly
that's right and what i'm gonna tell you
is
that has a shelf life to it
that's what i'm concerned about
and the closer you get to see years of
when you were abused directly
when you start getting passed around
from place to place in house to house
and adult to adult
the closer your kids get to those ages
the more your brain will begin to
unspool on you
and that's what i'm worried about
because they're
my four-year-old she's starting to
she's starting to ask me some difficult
questions that's right and
my policies i don't lie to her
good for you my policy is also to
protect her yep because i don't want her
to ever worry about things that i had to
worry about and i don't want her to she
doesn't even know that those things
exist but
but here's the thing here's the thing
let me be super clear with you okay can
i be direct with you is that cool
yeah absolutely i called you all right
so
tell me if i'm nuts
call me out if i'm wrong okay agreed
okay
yep
now that she's four
there's gonna be moments when you are
holding you are have her little bitty
four-year-old cheek in your hand at
night time and there's a little
nightlight on in that room
and you're either singing her a song or
you're telling her that you love her or
she's just babbling about something that
you don't even know she's talking
dragons and ponies or whatever
and
you are feeling that moment
and you are a thousand miles away
definitely
and you think something's wrong with you
and you try to get to another thing to
do
and this is where your brain
plays tricks on you and it actually it's
not playing tricks it is keeping you
safe because it has been down this road
before
and this road equals
torture
yep and so in many ways
your brain is at war with itself and
this is i'm just making up two parts of
the brain here um i'm not a
neuroscientist but
just for easy math for the for the
casual listener your frontal lobe knows
i need to do these things because my
daughters deserve better than what i got
yep and your amygdala knows
holy crap
adults and kids equal war
look out yeah and so it hides it is done
fighting and it couldn't flee when
you're four or in your six or when
you're 10
and somebody's sexually abusing you or
hitting you or just leaving you at
school and not picking you up whatever
crap you went through that you should
not have experienced
your brain knows
uh oh shift into neutral or out
and it just freezes is is that is that
fair
yeah we just hit a point at bedtime
where i i just gotta go yes yes yes and
my wife can't get out with my
two-year-old in enough time i just gotta
go that's right i feel horrible but well
no don't feel horrible
your brain's just trying to take care of
you because it's been down this road
before
and it doesn't it just sees bear it
doesn't know that's a nice bear it just
seems bare okay so just trying to love
you
and this is where
this is where i'm trying to carve a
third path
right down the middle of this country
there's a group of people who say you
need to suck it up and flex
just do the next right thing and it's
all about
yeah and you keep your hand there and
you tell her you right all that and that
there is some merit to that you gotta
keep showing up
and
the other story that's told
is well this happened to you this is all
you're ever gonna be
you just gotta deal with it
and it's just gonna be a thi and i don't
buy that either
there's a third way and it's both and
now is the season when the greatest gift
you could give your daughters is for you
to heal
to stop running stop hiding and stop
trying to fight it and to heal
and what that means is saying some of
this stuff out loud for the first time
ever in your life
an asus score of 10 you've read the
stuff haven't you
yeah and i and all i ever see about is
if you have a score before
and i don't see anything and it's it's
starting to concern me because it should
when you talk about
fight or flight like
i mean literally i won't pull into a gas
station if i can't get the first bumper
i can get in and get out that's right
that's right when i stop at a stop light
i give space in case i need to run
exactly i haven't i have no reason to
run but no dude you have every reason to
run because the two people on this earth
who were supposed to take care of you
didn't
they didn't
you're supposed to run brother
you are
in in a similar situation as my friends
who are veterans
who pull up to a stop sign and they they
have an escape route already planned
because they've been in fallujah they
know what's coming
or their brains do at least right that's
you man they you two people are supposed
to show up and they didn't they totally
left you hanging
yeah
and there is you got to hear me man
there is
a season
where you can show up to a gas station
and it doesn't even occur to you that
someone's coming after you
you can
be worried about the price for one
second exactly yeah
not dying it's it's cool just to
complain about gas prices not murder
right
there is a season where your wife can
reach over
during a movie where y'all watch on the
couch and she puts her hand on your leg
and your body doesn't tense up first
how do you know okay
there is a season dude where the phone
rings and you roll your eyes first your
heart just doesn't start beating
yeah okay and here's what i want for you
man i want you to have that peace
god almighty i want you to have that
peace
but you gotta decide i'm worth healing
and here's where i'm gonna be can i be
unfair to you for a second
yeah okay
you've done step one two and three of
the major work for your kids
i'm gonna keep doing these things but
what will happen over time is that
four-year-old and that six-year-old and
that ten-year-old and that
eighteen-year-old
they'll begin blaming themselves for the
gap between you and them
they will try to backfill that gap with
my dad is such an amazing man because
they're gonna play the facts out
dad always keeps us safe dad always
tells us good night dad always touches
us dad always sings dad always makes
sure we have food on the table dad's an
amazing guy but they can feel that they
are not relationally connected to you
and they will blame themselves for that
yeah and that's what i'm worried about
because like
my daughter asked me who my dad is
and
i
i i just stared at i didn't even like do
i even tell her his name like ah
so here's what you tell him
i tell you number one that's those are
those feeling triggers that's when you
write that stuff down i gotta deal with
that and i gotta deal with mom
and not that you're ever gonna take that
pain away that pain will always be there
but it will be something that doesn't
get your heart rate up anymore
they will be people in your past that
didn't show up and now we're on to the
next but we gotta wade through that
first and i'm when i say wade through it
not 18 years in therapy okay there are
some programs you can go 12 sessions and
work through this stuff
okay okay it's the trauma-focused stuff
there's emdr there is all kinds of
trauma-focused stuff there's even some
plant-based stuff that i've that i'm
reading about now for trauma like you've
experienced that's phenomenal okay
and with the map studies and things
they're continuing to roll it out and
roll it out and roll it out all to say
is healing is there but you got to go
down the road
and it is the bravest flex of all time
yeah
but i need you to hear me say there's
peace on the other end of this man
i hear you
just a
and you know that like the a score of
four just for the casual listener a
score of four is when all of a sudden
you see these weird spikes in cancer and
heart disease and they're bodies that
just eat themselves over time
a aces score of 10 is a dramatically
shorter life span if you don't deal if
you don't deal with it
every predictive metric suggests that
you're gonna have some major challenges
with addiction with disconnection with
numbing behaviors of some sort
and your body will just eat itself over
time
are you do you have any sort of
addictive tendencies at all
uh
no
i
or unplugging tendencies i tend to call
those yeah okay yeah so i i yeah i i i
tend to unplug okay
you can be totally alone in a crowded
room
oh yeah okay yeah you just you just go
in the deep elevator of your mind and
say bye and from a kid that was sexually
or
um physically abused that's where kids
go they get an elevator and they go so
deep inside so whatever is happening to
their body can happen they're adults in
their life you do what you're gonna do
i'm out of here but i'm still i'm i'm
it's my body but does that make sense
and that book yeah
the title says everything the body keeps
the score
your mind can hide but your body
registers everything
right and you know this i'm just i'm i'm
i'm using this to teach the listener too
um you know this
here's what i want you to do i want you
to be
do the bravest thing you've ever done
and you've done some brave stuff man
you're a hero to me right now dennis you
hear that
thank you like i talk to a lot of people
you're an impressive impressive young
man really impressive
i want you to call a trauma counselor in
your area
and i want you to say
i have an asus score of 10 and i'm ready
to do some healing
and if they can't handle it
they can't handle it in your area in in
a metropolitan area you're gonna you're
gonna be able to find some great folks
okay and there may be some
maybe some trial and error but you can
do it go ahead yeah i'm just i've
my wife's tried to encourage me and i'm
just so nervous just to
spill out and
and then
not like the person or
get judged by them or okay so here's the
thing
your story my brother is your story
nobody gets to judge it
nobody gets to comment on it it's your
story
and there will come a moment when that
story is so powerful both for you and
for those who hear it
that you'll begin to make meaning of
this thing after you've grieved this
childhood
you'll make meaning on the back end and
it will become a powerful narrative for
you and those around you
and right now that story feels scary
but if somebody can't handle that story
screw them you're on to the next
okay okay
nothing to be ashamed about you're a
dude you got robbed
you got robbed
yeah
and now you gotta call call the police
that's a terrible metaphor but you gotta
yeah you're gonna walk through it
yeah yeah you may have to go through one
or two counselors three or four great
you're worth it your kids are worth it
your wife is worth it stopping this
nonsense from ever happening to anybody
again and your legacy is worth it
yeah
and man
i'm so grateful to have gotten to talk
to you today brother
ah thanks you're oh man so grateful so
grateful um will you commit to letting
me uh can we we call you back you'll be
on the show again in a couple of months
yeah i'd love to walk alongside you in
this um as you go to counseling for the
first couple of times i'd love for you
to keep a journal at your home about how
it's going
and you can tell people what it's like
as you're experiencing this and let me
can i be honest with you it's going to
suck yeah it'll be real hard because
you're going to go back to hell but you
can have somebody with you this time
yeah i'm not looking forward to that
i've
been running from that for so long so
hard that it's it's scary to go back but
it is i stare at my kids and
and my wife is right i gotta face it
yeah but but that's that's why you go
with a trauma counselor because they're
gonna walk with you you're not gonna be
alone
you're gonna you're gonna go to trauma
counselor they're gonna walk with you
baby
this is legacy change this is setting
down those bricks in your backpack and
you've got like 30 cinder blocks i don't
even know how you're walking
the fact that you can get in and tell
your kids good night every night is
amazing the fact that you have found
somebody that you love and you are
connected to is a testament to your
strength and character
it's it's so so strong
but now i want you to be vulnerable for
a season
you built up the muscle you built up the
strength and you've got relationships
and now it's time to be be real
vulnerable and real brave
and then go
heal and then go heal
ah man i'm excited to walk alongside
with you on this one brother dennis
all right we are back hey during the
break
we stepped off and dennis who were just
on the phone with from milwaukee
asked kelly about another question and
so i'm going to bring dennis back man
you're hey dennis you're the first like
repeat call on the same show this is
incredible man
getting my money's worth today yeah dude
so what's up yeah exactly and this
advice by the way is
worth every penny you're paying for it
it's awesome
um so hey man so what's up dude
all right so yeah so i i mentioned that
my mom had come back and i what
president
what happened for that is my
father-in-law passed away back in
february okay
is he a good man he's a good man
uh he was the best grandparent that
my kids had by far he was a great man
and it it was horrible man he
he had parkinson's and dementia and it
was a two or three year spiral where he
ended up
dying obviously and
my wife and i were
his main caretakers throughout that
process yeah lee dude
somebody give dennis a break man
god almighty dude that's
that is hard
it was
horrible and
so anyway throughout this process
my mother decided that she had a calling
to come back
i bet she did
i bet she's a good grandparent for my
kids
and
so i just i got to be honest with you i
always want to give my bias up front
not a huge your mom fan right now cool
yeah okay i don't want to talk crap
about anybody's mom not a huge fan but
go ahead so she she gets a call she gets
the gets the call
yeah so i've had 30 i i've had 30 years
of from both my parents but from her too
things will be better things be better
i'm going to do more and no action ever
followed up
this year john
she's come and visited my house three
times now which is more than i've seen
her
in like a decade before that
so what in the world compelled you to
allow that
i'm not judging you this is just two
dudes having a beer at a bar dude like
what are you doing
i just always
felt
like not being the resentful nasty
person yes and
if you're gonna make the effort to
to have a good relationship i've always
tried to have my door open and it's it's
hard
but
i've just been like oh
like in the past i've paid for her to
come back just to try to have a
relationship with her and now this year
she's come back and paid for herself
three times yeah and she was just here a
couple weeks ago
and my kids love her man yeah
it's hard yeah
so
a common thread
with children from with
parents who abandoned them
or
from
parents who abused them
you have both
a common adult thread is a continuation
a continuing of
the kid trying to go back and heal that
relationship
every kid has it wired in that why would
my parents not love me it must be me
remember earlier i was talking to you
about your daughters they'll start to
feel that gap yeah you still feel that
gap
you paid for a tiger that shredded your
heart and mind and soul you paid for her
to come back and be in your house with
your kids
and when you say it like that it sounds
insane right
yeah but there is a four-year-old inside
of you that is still going what the hell
did i do wrong
yeah and i can make it right now now
that i got money now that i got my own
house now that i got my stuff together
mom will you love me now
yeah
and uh man uh you you listen to the show
for more than five minutes you know i'm
all about redemption
all day every day
but i'm not about getting bit by the
same rattlesnake twice
yeah so
on that note my specific question was
and
maybe you'll guide me differently i
don't know but how so i've
i've rebuilt an entire different life
with my wife and my kids as i mentioned
we're
we're sound in every way possible and i
had to
do a lot of work to get here
and
like is there a way that i can
how do i let the past be the past with
her and if she
is changed which sounds crazy
how have i built something new and
different with her
incredible questions both of them
the answer number one is
she doesn't have access to your kids
until you've healed
until you're okay
and so when mom can call and your heart
rate doesn't take off on you
when
you and your wife talk about mom
and you don't instantly get thrown back
26 years
when you've healed
then you can start the conversation
about what does it look like to let this
tiger back in
because you're gonna realize
you're you've grown a lot of muscles and
you're big
and you're gonna the part of healing
trauma work is letting this little
eight-year-old that's been trying to
protect you for the last 30 years
letting them off the hook
and that's just hard to do
let them out of the elevator and that's
just part of it and again it can be as
as easy as 12 sessions
some sometimes it's harder than that
it's longer than that but you got to
heal
so um
i'm trying to think of i i'm just
getting flooded with lame analogies but
if i mean if you cut yourself with a
knife
you let your finger heal before you
start doing the same thing with a knife
again you know what i mean
um you're not you're not healed yet
and then the second thing is after
you're healed you sit down with mom and
have some very direct
boundary oriented conversations here's
how this is gonna go cause this is my
house now
and i live through it in your house
you're in my home now
and that's not disrespectful
that is boundaries that is safety
that is you
saying if you're going to be a part of
our lives
you person who abandoned me abused me
let other people use me
if you're back in around my kids and
around my wife
it's gonna look like this
and it will be an extraordinary olive
branch
period for you allowing that
but right now you're not okay and so
when grandma comes you tense up
when you see your kids playing with
grandma your heart is out the door on
you when your grandma's behind closed
doors with one of your daughters or one
of your daughters says hey i gotta go
potty and grandma says i'll take her
right
yeah
yeah am i right
yeah no you're right so you will come
healing first
and it might be a year
hey now's not a good time for you to
come over
um i'm in some pretty intensive
counseling right now mom working through
my childhood
and when i'm ready for you to come back
then we'll i'd love for you to but i'm
not ready yet
and you leave it at that and that dude
that's gonna be the first little brick
out of your backpack that's going to
become the road you're going to walk on
and your kids are going to walk on the
road and your wife's going to walk on
that road and your grandkids are going
to walk on that road and it's going to
feel a little bit lighter the first time
you lay down that first little boundary
and then you're gonna get feel stronger
and stronger and stronger
but yeah brother she doesn't have a
it's
i don't mean this in a demeaning way but
you got a fantasy in your head that you
can make this all okay
and in a weird perverse way you've done
a lot of this work to prove to mom that
you're lovable now
oh yeah absolutely and
and for my dad too and that's messed up
you know what i mean
yeah yeah there's a little kid in there
man that's still trying to like look
look look i got a marriage and she loves
me and she's pretty and my two kids
they're well behaved and they follow
directions and i hug them before bed am
i doing good mom am i doing good
that's what you got to heal from
you don't got to live that life man they
don't get a vote in your life anymore
they cash that out
they cashed that out
they don't get a vote they don't get an
opinion they don't get anything until
you are well enough to let them back in
with boundaries on your terms
so can we go dark for a second
yeah
what happens if mom hurts one of your
daughters
[Laughter]
let me tell you it's been about 12 hours
she's dead and i'm in jail
you're
i i haven't thought about it but that's
the first place i won exactly rage so
let me just tell you
i've seen this happen
the risk is not worth the reward at this
point
how do i
how do i have that conversation with my
kids age-appropriate and
they they grandma's
i mean they don't
they're four man
you're putting a lot
rightfully so but you're putting a lot
of insight and truth into their minds
that aren't there yet
so
they will quickly
let me put it this way i took my
four-year-old my wife was
doing some work in brazil she's a
brilliant researcher she was doing some
work with a school in brazil and
me and my son he was
two or three at the time we tagged along
for something like that
dude my son and i picked mangoes off of
trees and avocados off of trees they
were the size of my head and we
two cans were just wild and they landed
i mean we it was the most amazing
adventure between with me and my son
like in a stroller down cobblestone it
was amazing
he doesn't remember any of it nothing
none of it man he has no recollection of
it and like you know we wrote on a
donkey out into the jungle he has
nothing no recollection so i tell you
that to tell you
your
your connection memories with your kids
are forming their their neural
connections
their memories though are very very thin
at this moment in their life
so
grandma won't come around and one of
them may be like where's grandma be like
she's at home oh okay when's she gonna
come see us oh she'll come somewhere
sometime
okay and it'll be on to the next
it'll be on to the next
okay
so don't overthink it you're gonna use
your kids as a proxy to get connected to
your parents don't do that
draw that boundary with mom and let mom
know i'm in counseling now i'm dealing
with my childhood i got little kids and
um
you're coming back and it's all coming
back real hard and i appreciate you
coming back um but i gotta do some
healing first and then we'll we'll
figure out what this is gonna look like
moving
forward and that's that's tiny little
boundary number one
can you do that
yeah
dude i'd love for you to do that and
then write me an email let me know how
that goes would you do that
yeah dude that would be rad that's
setting that first boundary
sitting that first time and everybody
listening to the show this is right
after the holidays
some of y'all know i got to set
boundaries now too
very few of you will have to set
boundaries like dennis is having a set
everybody can do it
dennis you're leading the charge here
okay
all right that sounds scary but yeah you
are redeeming your story my brother
you're redeeming those bricks that
you've been carrying around they're
gonna turn into pathways they're going
to turn to old brick roads that other
people are going to walk on dude you're
redeeming your story and you're going to
help a lot a lot of people
put that courage and hey mom may throw a
walleyed fit
or she may send you crazy text messages
about you're killing me and my babies
you're gonna hold this over my head why
won't you forgive me
all of that is manipulative abusive
nonsense
uh you know her well you get a right to
heal
you get a right to heal
trust me
yeah all right my brother
god it's been it's been an honor honor
honor to talk to you so great man